right now all eyes are on Wisconsin
where the voters are determining whether
to key incumbent Governor Scott Walker
or replace him with Milwaukee Mayor Tom
Barrett many see this election as a
referendum not just for you know
governor Scott Walker but also the
policies that he tried to implement to
curb public employee unions negotiating
power over their contracts because of
the national ramifications of what's
going on Wisconsin the reason root poll
actually went into Wisconsin and survey
about 700 Wisconsin residents to find
out what they think about the
controversial law and also how they plan
to vote on june fifth
part of Wisconsin act 10 was to ask
public employee unions to increase what
they contribute to their own health care
from six percent to twelve percent to
the cost of their health care
overwhelmingly Wisconsin voters approve
of this provision
a lot of polls in 2011 came out asking
people if they favor or opposed reducing
collective bargaining rights of public
employee unions and overwhelmingly
people said no we asked the same
question but didn't use the word rights
all we said was would you favor or
oppose limiting collective bargaining
the results flip and then a majority
favored limiting collective bargaining
interestingly Governor Walker exempted
public safety unions those you know
firefighters and police officers from
some of the most controversial aspects
of the law so we asked wisconsin'
residents what they thought and a
majority opposed exempting them from the
law
proponents of the law say that public
employee unions have too much political
power and thus to reform public employee
unions that power needs to be limited so
we asked Wisconsin residents if public
employee unions when negotiating their
contracts have too much power not enough
power or about the right amount and we
found a plurality said that public
employee unions had too much power and
negotiating their contracts however a
plurality is not a majority and in part
this is indicative of many people not
knowing what collective bargaining
actually is and if you don't know what
it is it's hard to determine if someone
has too much power these results tell us
that Wisconsin voters aren't quite ready
to oust Governor Scott Walker from
office in fact fifty percent plan to
vote for him on june fifth this is
especially interesting given that
President Barack Obama leads Mitt Romney
in the state by 10 percentage points in
the presidential election in fact
quarter of those who plan to vote for
scott walker have a favorable opinion of
president obama the fact that many
Walker supporters also support President
Barack Obama demonstrates that the
desire to reform public employee unions
extends beyond partisan lines